ils sont douze étudiants en master
internationale à venir en escapade dans
le chablisien première étape se répartir
entre les familles d'accueil
[Musique]
mais les étudiants chez eux pour qu'ils
puissent installer et rendez vous à midi
feralia ali et boudicca sont originaires
d'inde et du sri-lanka ils sont
accueillis par leurs hôtes sarah leur
propose d'effectuer un petit tour du
propriétaire
la vue sur le vignoble du chablisien est
imprenable une tranche de nature pour
ces deux étudiants en électronique
appliquée
nous préparer
c'est la possibilité de venir en pleine
campagne je pense que quand ils sont
arrivés à dijon il me disait justement
depuis qu'ils sont arrivés d'un an à
dijon ils sont ils sont jamais sortis
dijon en fait la commune de fleury s'est
proposé pour accueillir les étudiants ce
village viticole et déjà engagés dans
les préparatifs de la prochaine saint
vincent tournante en février un aspect
traditionnel incontournable ici
n'insistez pas forcément sur le côté
saint vincent fête du vin mais par
contre c'est l'idée de leur montrer la
vie d'un village en fête on est dans un
village vont s'entraîner très
régulièrement de toute façon au
quotidien en général donc on avait envie
leur parti faire partager vivre la vie
d'un village
et dans le respect des traditions un
bambin guignon pour l'accueil des
étudiants s'imposait
je vis sur le campus tout le monde est
concentré sur ses études et c'est
difficile de se faire des amis ici je
suis vraiment content d'être entouré et
d'apprécier la compagnie de toucy
être ici c'est vraiment un très grand
plaisir pour moi c'est très agréable et
la vue est tellement belle je pense que
j'aurais bien apprécié
petite séance photo avant d'aller à la
découverte du village les étudiants ont
prévu de se rendre sur le marché de
chablis ce week end et de découvrir la
cité médiévale de noyers sur serein